welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness just confirmed the
huge impact one division will have on
this movie by bringing back wanda's
children billy and tommy in the latest
trailer in the same exact westview house
set from that series but do they exist
did they ever exist are all of us just
mere figurines and gus's fish tank well
the exact nature of billy and tommy
where they went and how and why they are
back now in multiverse of madness
remains one of the biggest unresolved
questions from wandavision so let's
break down where they've been and how
exactly they're now returning in this
film let's rewind the clock billy and
tommy first appeared in wanovision
episode 3 conceived not out of any
biological means with vision despite
paul bettany assuring us that it is
purple and it's spectacular but really
as a manifestation of wanda's sitcom hex
the way sitcom actresses pregnancies
would be worked into the plots and the
way those kids would suddenly age up and
get recast between episodes sometimes
now at the time you remember many of us
were convinced that those boys were
going to be revealed as part of billy
and tommy's origin from the marvel
comics babysat by act the harkness but
revealed to be puppets of master
pandemonium using fragments of his
master mephisto all part of a scheme to
steal wanda's chaos magic kids later on
in the comics becoming the object of
wanda's obsession in the amazing house
of m event as she villainously warped
reality to try to reach a reality where
she's with her kids once more until
after a major alternate universe
conflict leads with her declaring no
more mutants in racing a lot of mutants
from the marvel universe until later on
in the comics some mephisto magic allows
these two kids to respawn as the mutants
and young avengers wicken and speed and
along with many parallels to those
original west coast avenger comics one
division totally teased us with dialogue
in which pietro calls the two boys demon
spawn unleash hell demon spawn now
throughout the episodes billy and tommy
evolved into their wiccan in speed forms
billy capable of harnessing sorcery the
way wanda does tommy a speedster like
his uncle pietro agave kidnapped them in
episode 7 and revealed them in episode 8
strung by the neck an image that i could
not help but see as puppets again to the
master pandemonium panel my goal with
these videos is to have them dripping
with insight but you know it's not fun
to have drip wet feet after you
accidentally stepped into a puddle
doesn't that suck soggy socks have been
ranked among the top 12 day ruiners for
years but there is a simple solution to
get rid of them you just gotta wear some
sleek comfortable vessy shoes thanks to
bessie for sponsoring this video
besties are the perfect everyday shoe
they are sustainably made knit sneakers
that are 100 waterproof they are made
with this dymatex material that is super
easy to clean with just a rinse of water
oh no
i spilled water all over my feetsy
wheatsies but my oinky oinkies are blown
dry like the dune seed thanks messy
whatever this season bessies are truly
the everyday shoe banish those soggy
socks forever besties are my go-to shoes
by my door so check them out in the link
below with a pair of your own vessy
shoes but of course the one division
finale left our theories high and dry in
all kinds of ways but when it comes to
billy and tommy a big reason for that
was a deleted sequence that would have
given them a lot more to do in this
finale as the series director matt
shakman confirmed to kevin smith and
mark bernardin on the fat man beyond
podcast we did have a whole sequence
where darcy monica
ralph meet up with the kids and they're
in agatha's house and they they think
that maybe they should steal the
darkhold um from the basement because
the kids had seen it when they were down
there being held hostage by agatha and
they go down there to get the book and
they're reaching for the book and the
rabbit hops up in front of the book and
they're like oh it's saying you're
scratchy he's the best and they like
reach over to pet him and he like hisses
and then this whole american werewolf in
london transformation happens and the
rabbit turns into this big demon right
into her like familiar you know and uh
and then gooney's set piece ensues with
all sorts of fun as they try to escape
from the rabbit yes sinner scratchy the
rabbit was intended to be agatha's
familiar a demon in disguise guardian of
the darkhold book transfigured via
witchcraft into an innocent household
form ultimately the boys like vision
inside of this hex were truly spawned by
wanda herself manifestations of her
grief her dream family that she wished
she could have had with vision had he
not been killed by thanos so in episode
9 when wanda decided to drop that hex
from the westfield borders vision and
the boys were erased along with it but
after tucking them in wanda said to them
thanks for choosing me to be your mom
and yes i understand that this is a
sentimental expression many a parent has
said to their child but in this context
it does ring as at least a bit curious
considering billy and tommy's mysterious
origins especially when you consider the
post-credits scene where wanda reads the
darkhold and hears these boys calling
out to her from beyond
and that takes us to now in footage for
multiverse madness wanda conducts a
seance that transports her mentally back
into that same west view home with billy
and tommy on the couch a fire blazing in
the hearth and cartoons playing on the
tv now i pointed out in the breakdown
that this cartoon is an old walt disney
oswald and ortenzia short from 1928
called skyscrapers this is pre-mickey
mouse era this being a symbol of the
erased history that could have been had
universal not taken walt's beloved
rabbit from him which led to our
timeline where steamboat willie starring
mcmaus dominated our history and i see
this as a reflection of how all of this
this suburban ideal with billy and tommy
and who knows maybe vision cook and
pepper cache in the kitchen was erased
from existence forgotten retconned until
wanda demands attention must be paid so
i think this reunion with billy and
tommy is a direct continuation of the
one division post-credits scene a vision
haunting wanda a reality she tries to
use her witchcraft to recreate but like
any mirage when you reach out to try to
touch it it vanishes and slips through
your fingers so if billy and tommy were
never corporeally real in the mcu but
rather manifestations of wanda's grief
who or what is using them now to try to
get to wanda who is sending her these
projections i think the answer to that
question is going to tell us why the
multiverse is so mad who wants it to get
madder and what it will look like on the
other side of this crisis now i have
speculated a number of demonic entities
could be corrupting wanda of course our
daddy methisto nightmare and yeah plenty
of signs and footage are pointing to
c'thun author of the darkhold and the
demon who initially cursed wanda with
her chaos magic when she's a baby and if
there is a darker demonic force behind
all of this gathon does make a lot of
sense and i also dig that idea that his
ingary minions in the trailer could be
the demon spawn that billy and tommy
were based on the way singer scratchy
was a demon in disguise when it comes to
mephisto folks i'm gonna be okay waiting
for daddy to come out of the shadows
until like midnight suns or you know any
time i close my eyes oh hey daddy but
perhaps the more interesting conflict
here and i think trailer footage is
backing this up is wanda versus wanda in
the past i've shared the theory that the
way multiverse of madness might adapt
the house of m storyline is by
suggesting that the marvel cinematic
universe is not the core main marvel
universe and that the truth that
professor x wants to tell us now is that
what we have been watching since 2008 is
a flawed incomplete side universe where
mutants have been like poor oswald
forgotten erased from our memories that
we are not living in a house of m but
rather a meson du mespri a house of
misery and that the person who cast that
runes of cough call style retcon that
resulted in the spawning of this new
reality was this other wanda in her
reality she had children mutants existed
but then some past house of m conflict
with her ended with her declaring no
more mutants that gave us our current
mutant lists mcu but our mcu wanda as a
nexus being was so broken by grief that
when she cast her west view hex the
family she populated it with were her
sons from that other wanted reality and
when she did that her pocket reality
opened a gateway and sent a signal to
her variant that now mcuanda needs her
help and that help takes the form of
these nightmares and these voices in
which her sons beg arwanda to fix this
reality so that they can now be back
with her once more and when that happens
spawning along with them in the mcu is
to be every oswald and aurora who were
stolen from our memories and the fact
that we're seeing patrick stewart
charles xavier might be the way
multiverse of madness justifies why evan
peters played pietro and wanda's hex now
i know i know the understanding in the
weeks after wandavision was that evan
peters was just a sitcom recasting joke
and that ralph boner was just some actor
living in new jersey that might end up
being the case folks but i will direct
you to matt shachman's own words about
the disappointment some people felt that
evan peters wasn't quicksilver what i
would say to the to the marvel fan who's
a little disappointed that the x-men
didn't show up or the multiverse didn't
show up um clearly right there
is that they're coming you know they're
coming right you've got a movie called
multiverse of madness you've got mutants
announced at comic-con a year and a half
ago like they're coming and time has
proven him right multiverse of madness
is here and the fox x-men are in it so
marvel has an opportunity to reframe all
of the mcu and the lingering mysteries
from one division as the creations of
another wanda who needs her mcu variant
to fix her mistakes and in doing that
give us deadpool and storm give me give
me community you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at avos follow new
rockstars subscribe to the rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you